a t elle à nu les à-côtés l'hôpital d un
côté le fita les esclaves émissaire
j'ai les logis de
me carlo et nous de l'association la
sauce rock en ville elle créée en 1993
et depuis 1993 nous fait la
manifestation du 20 décembre et à chaque
fin décembre nous présente une
exposition et en 1998 de la décidé de
faire des effets de recherches
généalogiques et n'a constaté que ici en
1848 et il ya des patronymes que mon
esclave de cette captation la gagner
patronyme ne la retenir c'est le
patronyme carlo et que nous regarde le
village à villèle nous constate que le
patronyme l'aller on est encore là et la
prend
un jeune du quartier à saint carlo et on
a fait des recherches généalogiques et
ses nuits également la mairie de
saint-paul et après nous la montre
jusqu'à les archives à nous la pâte
comme ça fait des recherches et
généalogie n'espère pas tombé sur un
très très bon résultat voire 20 très
très grande surprise on a tombé sur une
ancienne esclave et
et quittera t travail et travail a été à
la fois ça nous présentons les à-côtés
l'hôpital nostra et c'était scarlett et
véronique parlour fille aînée 11 ans
dans la même la cc dans ses plantations
mais dans les années 1770 et d'ailleurs
il est mort aussi ici à villèle en 1852
il dans ce cadre dans un mémo ration de
la bourriche a fait de la liberté on va
dire
et il fallait bien présenté cette
technologie c'est pour ça que vous avez
de la paix appelle à une artiste fait
anne-marie valencien et à saint-arnoult
la partie plusieurs fois dans son
atelier dans sa case le massage les eaux
près de l'église saint généraux il a à
cet art de la paix faire son portrait et
l'artiste paix tram arrive à lancia a
dessiné une généalogie pour notre
association et regarde bien positif au
regard de la généalogie regarde en bas
en baroja diel et les traits noirs les
sombres et plus immonde de la généalogie
free se dit j'ai ça devient clair l'idée
de l'artiste de nous-mêmes bien sûr
était de présenter ses côtés sombres de
la force de l'esclavagé primeau et puis
si tony werner verrait la lumière on va
dire que à l'époque de 29 ans est à san
carlos des mots difficiles avait pas
trop de sourires et plus on monte en
l'air puis s'ils vont dans les arrêts
génération et puis il ya ces sourires
qu'on peut voir sur le visage des arts
scène par l'eau